thank you
DC Comics made a big announcement at San
Diego Comic-Con revealing an upcoming
epic battle between the legendary
monster verse and the DC Universe the
series titled Justice League vs Godzilla
vs Kong will be a collaboration with
legendary comics and Toho International
it will feature seven issues and is set
to release on October 17
2023 written by Brian buccelato known
for his work on the flash and Injustice
and with art by Christian Deuce from
Batman fortnite zero points the story
will start with a clash between the
Justice League and the Legion of Doom
but takes an unexpected turn when
Godzilla Kong and the most diverse
tyrants entered DC's Earth the resulting
battle will be a massive and destructive
crossover event exploring such what-if
scenarios where different fandoms
Collide especially superheroes and giant
monster universes
so the main question now is which
superheroes of the Justice League will
have the strength or the abilities to
defeat the king of the monsters we will
sadly leave Kong aside for now and only
focus on the G-Man we will take a look
at each of the seven main members of the
Justice League and assess their
strengths and weaknesses versus the king
of the monsters remember that way back
in the past there was a crossover event
between the Avengers and Godzilla it
took all of them at once to make it a
fair and even fight so now with the
Justice League will it be different or
will one of them be enough or will there
be none able to stop the Big G so let's
get to it
firstly Wonder Woman starting off with
maybe the only DC Superhero who has
actually had an arch enemy in the form
of a gigantic entity one a woman has for
a long time been an odds with giganta
winning fights by sheer willpower and
strategy since the giant woman's
strength was too much even for Diana
Prince however with Godzilla things are
quite different firstly he is a
radioactive Titan with atomic powers and
no doubt more durable and stronger than
giganta Wonder Woman even with her
incredible Feats of Strength and Agility
and also speed will not be enough to
defeat Godzilla the most she can do is
to annoy him with blows to his face and
body and to be fair Godzilla might not
even be able to catch her since she
would be too fast and cunning but a
well-timed strike would easily knock her
out for a Time allowing him to finish
her with an atomic breath
okay number two cyball Victor Stone a
prominent member of the Justice League
is a half human half machine superhero
who gained his incredible Powers through
a life-changing accident Cyborg's body
has been heavily augmented with Advanced
alien technology and a mother box
enhancements this Fusion of human and
machine grants him a vast array of
abilities he has superhuman strength and
can fire energy blasts from various
parts of his body but none of these can
do a thing to Godzilla his best tool
however is his mind which is now part
machine possessing all types of sensors
with it he would be able to scan
Godzilla to search for a weakness to
defeat the G-Man I'm betting that he
would be able to find out everything
about Godzilla's biology in a short
amount of time and create the DC's
version of an oxygen Destroyer weapon to
nullify the G-Man so surprisingly he
would fare much better than Wonder Woman
against the king of the monsters
number three The Flash Speedy Gonzalez
here with half as much of a chance at
beating Godzilla as Wonder Woman but
since he is super fast he wouldn't be
caught by the Big G either he can run at
incredible velocities faster than speed
of sound and maybe even light he can
move so fast that he can appear to be in
multiple places at once but the powers
of his blows even with the speed force
behind them wouldn't really do much to
Godzilla here who shrugs off tank shells
like nothing so what I'm saying here is
neither can The Flash defeat the G-Man
nor can Godzilla defeat the Flash
number four Aquaman fish boy here would
be neck deep in Troubled Waters there is
absolutely no chance of these two
characters not meeting in the ocean and
dueling to find out who would be the
ruler of the Seas Aquaman the ruler of
Atlantis considers the world's oceans as
his domain you know who else does the
same the king of the monsters yeah he is
a primarily aquatic Titan that regularly
patrols the world's Waters in search for
threats to his dominance Atlantis like
the one in the master verse is the
domain of Godzilla and therefore there
is bound to be a battle one-on-one
Godzilla Takes the Cake easily but
Aquaman has an entire Army as well as a
giant master in the karathan that is way
bigger than Godzilla and would battle
the king of the Masters until one of
them is dead but even then the results
of such a conflict would be indecisive
so surprisingly Aquaman would fare
better than one woman
number five the Green Lantern the Green
Lantern ring is one of the most powerful
weapons in the DC Comics Universe its
powers derived from the green light of
willpower harnessed by the Green Lantern
core an Intergalactic police foes the
ring is capable of creating virtually
anything its wearer can imagine limited
only by the user's willpower creativity
and Imagination but the power behind the
ring is an absolute massive blunt force
can shatter the constructs and fear
could override the green energy what
does Godzilla have which is prominent
aside from his size Atomic powers and
durability an immense super species will
and the ability to strike fear in even
other Master Titans and him being a
benevolent Titan as well as a protector
of the natural order might even make the
ring choose him as the guardian of the
sector leaving the current wearer aside
from that there is not much that the
Green Lantern alone could do to stop
Gojira or his counter attacks number six
Batman The Dark Knight is just a man so
forget a physical fight forget his
normal gadgets too or any of the armors
he has in his possession the one thing
that bats have to his Advantage is his
mind he is known for his intelligence
strategic thinking and preparation which
he could use to increase his chances of
success he is a master inventor and
could create specialized gadgets or
weapons designed to counter Godzilla's
specific abilities these could include
powerful energy-based weapons Advanced
Vehicles large Mecca robots as seen in
the artwork tease for the upcoming
comics while this is likely a silver
lining the scenario however is Bleak in
such a crossover event Batman would have
absolutely no clue as to what Godzilla
is there would be no prior preparation
time no time or resources to construct a
Mecca if he was alone that is and the
best he could do is maybe take some time
off study the creature and eventually
make an oxygen destroy weapon but that
might not be enough either as in a
surprise encounter there isn't much a
man can do
and number seven Superman suits the
power behind the league is the best
chance in fighting and defeating
Godzilla in a crossover event but this
all depends on which continuity or age
he is taken from Superman Prime or
All-Star Superman can easily defeat
Godzilla he has near Godlike Powers but
other Superman versions like golden age
or even modern era soups will definitely
not have enough strength to counter the
Big G the most of us Titan has one thing
that is almost as fatal to soups as
Kryptonite his Atomic power there have
been more than one or two occasions that
Superman had been struck by a nuclear
explosion and that left him
incapacitated and extremely weakened
well surprise surprise Godzilla
witnessed nuclear pulse and a near
unlimited Atomic power would not just
weaken the Kryptonian but leave him in a
state of vulnerability that Godzilla's
physical attacks could actually finish
off the man in blue but then again
Superman on the other hand is no push
over he could speed attack God right
through the heart if he feels that he
shouldn't hold back any of his powers in
order to stop the Titan so this could be
a tie
so that's the video I hope you have
enjoyed watching it anyway do hit that
like button for support and subscribe to
push us through the YouTube algorithm
but most of all smash the Bell icon for
regular updates and new videos here on
this channel availability That's all
folks